as soon as the
fight ends this is the press conference
go well the judge got wrong on that one
did they
but did they so dana has so much power
and when he says that the
the sheep
for lack of a better word the sheep go
dana said he didn't win he didn't win
it's like dude come up with your own
opinion man go back and watch that fight
and i wish dana would wait until he
watched the fight like we saw the fight
watch it a second or third time before
you jump to that conclusion because by
saying that
that gives everybody out there the
casuals the mma experts especially on
espn or if you work for ufc now all of
them go algerman yet you know he didn't
win that fight which isn't true
it's just not true nobody got cheated
out of anything that was a close [ __ ]
fight that's why there's a split
decision in that second or third round
i believe they should give
10 8 out more frequently to dominate a
guy that long be on his back that long
and control a guy for that long
i'm not mad at ten eight but they didn't
give it to eight that's fine so we know
al jermain won the second and third lost
the fourth fifth was closer
but we'll give fourth and fifth to yon
two and three no debate there's no
argument algerman completely dominate
completely dominated i would have liked
a 10-8 for maybe that second or third
round but all right we don't get that so
you gotta go to the first round this
whole fight is predicated off one round
so for anybody including dana white or
any mma expert out there to go he didn't
win that fight
i'd love to hear the argument
i'd love to hear the argument because
you're because if you're based in that
first round you're saying because peter
yon was the aggressor he won the fight
because he was the aggressor won that
first round
because octagon control which is what
that is when you're marching forward
when you're the aggressor that's the
last thing that the judges should judge
it based off of you're judging based off
damage and strikes landed
so let's go to the numbers let's go to
the numbers because remember
the last thing being judged is octagon
control
so
strikes landed right and who's doing the
most damage so let's go to the first two
things that matter the most
perion landed i think two kicks in the
first round
sterling landed more shots through more
shots
i didn't come up with a criteria
i don't come up with the judging you
guys did
based off that criteria al germain won
that first round
that's not al germain come up with the
judging he didn't come up with the
scoring criteria
the commission did you guys did
that were at the mercy of that judging
criteria based off that criteria this is
very black and white
algerman sterling based off your judging
criteria won that first round
hands down
no argument
based off your criteria
that we all have to go off of
that i have nothing to do al germain has
nothing to do with it based off the
criteria that you guys always go off of
al jermain won that first round
very black and white close round 100
i'll give you that but based off those
important factors strikes landed damage
inflicted
last one you're going to go to is
octagon control and peter young won that
one we lost the first two so who would
you give the round to al germain so say
al germain won the first round
in what
[ __ ] world do you live in where you
wouldn't give him another two rounds in
the second and third
based off your criteria that i didn't
design that i i'm at the mercy like you
guys are and the fighters are based off
those criterias
so algerman won the first round
completely dominate the second round
completely dominate the third round
definitely lost the fourth round
fifth round was close but i'll give it
to yon
that's three out of five
that would make him world champion
but when you're the president of the ufc
you have a responsibility
so when you say
the judges got it wrong on that one well
now you [ __ ] out jermaine sterling
over
now you [ __ ] him
because he
beat the naysayers he beat the haters
he shut everybody up but not resurfaces
because the most powerful man in the ufc
says he didn't win that fight
which you don't know what you're talking
about
you're wrong dude and you [ __ ] your
fighter over so now he has to go back to
the drawing where he has to deal with
more of this stupid [ __ ] hate and why
because he won three out of five